[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on compte au moins compliqué au tour du
sénateur est une sorte de gourmandise ne
finit pas en douceur
[Musique]
si la voilà est vite arrivé et lille et
je la porte aux crocs y'a qu'à ou chez
le délice des danish elle est unique au
monde est confectionnée spécialement
pour le creux jacques de quoi parle du
mot comme et de ce que je porte le
présenter un petit bout de bâle et bat
c'est une fille antijeu voilà l'exploit
passé le grand yaka l'attend il va chez
régal si à l'automne comptines pour un
bon moment
obama va tenir en un brevet war bay when
your grave ayant de grands à aba koita
voici la hausse car si l'industrie cieux
une valeur élevée ici perso je vais vous
savoir de combien
ceci cela allez vous promener elle et
laissez-moi scène j'ai besoin de me
concentrer et alors il est là mais évite
muscadet fait de pâques et je suis
content
elle est bien la france ce dim oscars ça
tue pas on croit qu'un chat dépend
relève le papier et je voulais avoir des
semaines j'ai du mal à casser au hockey
les bleus mais l'ubs et les bleus
comment moitié à c'est un chef-d'oeuvre
crayats cas on est là non une sucette à
la fraise et rome l es tu foutais là les
mots ce carré je veux rester seul parce
que j'ai besoin de me recueillir sur ma
sucette à la fraise et quelle aubaine
je vis avait passé deux heures dans mon
petit pôle nord secret eh bien je
disparais grand yaka je disparais un
fils je vais me régaler nous avons la
paix pour un bon moment
mba obame
quelle chance vous dire en tant le petit
banc mais j'avais le grand kaka ne veut
voir personne pendant qu'ils s'occupent
de chats chercher un ballon propre et
onguents c'est la tête d'ibm le succès
bonjour moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
écoutez en tirer la voie du grand yaka
au secours d'une voix unique c'est bien
celle du grand yaka relais de muscat et
surtout de bien lui et l'appel au
secours on n'est jamais tranquille avec
ce grand yaka weepu jamais il ne peut
être malade de secours reçu coup alors
une histoire doit rester ces casses toi
moi je suis conne et aller jusqu'à 100
jeunes quoi tu ta vie à moscou
je suis collé vous avoir un travail peu
ma barbe au mahb et le bob de dieu
attitude j'avais des ps puis à l'évier
dit-il 8 me de caunes est d'un goût fait
et vous ne sentira rien aux méthodes
déjà il était devenu millions puis celle
des gens meurent chez les têtes arrêté
un menu il ya un autre moyen grand gars
corps oui oui si c'était bien le retrait
bien lire notre moyen condition que
c'est le fespam a eu aucun mal grand
yaka vous maniez saison oui je vais tout
simplement couper votre barbe et vos
moustaph nous nous sentirions et vous
ferez des collègues sans âme même encore
oui nous couper les barbus me couper les
moustaches et moi qui suis ciboure a
jamais jamais jamais allée ceci c'est là
un pari fou de titus il veut me défiguré
allait désormais neuf attrapés le m
ferme les belles siège est à voir
il paraît que ressortir et de lacan la
zone du grand yaka fera fondu et après
après
en est une autre victoire
[Musique]